the people of uganda
have not elected a new president they've
got the old one back
for a six successive turn i would feel
confident
that they are presidential
and that's absolutely fine with this
group of motorcycle riding yueri
museveni supporters
one of africa's longest serving leaders
president museveni
has claimed 58 of the vote
outmaneuvering his youthful rival
bobby wine in a contentious and violent
campaign
yet millions of ugandans seem happy with
the result
the 76 year old president addressed the
nation
promising to govern with total integrity
political actors
act only in the interests of the people
not in the interest of anything yes
not in the interest of the elite
not not in the interest of foreigners
not in the interests of this group or
that
or or that elite group but in the
interest of the people the ordinary
people
but there are a lot of people in this
country who do not trust him
and at a ramshackle pool hall in kampala
bobby wine supporters said they couldn't
stomach another five years of a
president
they call granddad
we don't like him he's cheated us
his direction
when members of the ruling party tried
to hold a victory rally
things got heated but the organizer
called
obama hussein said museveni is basically
perfect his system is also perfect
so we're after the system not somebody
else that is in power
the system is so so perfect
that's not a popular view among younger
ugandans
who delivered the president's party an
unmistakable message
national television news informing the
public that more than 25
cabinet ministers had lost their seats
but the performance of our ministers and
many of our mps especially around
the central region has been a real
shocker it's something that we need to
go back and investigate and find out
opposition leader bobby wine was not
seen in public
despite the fact that he'd won 3.5
million votes
his home outside kampala had been
surrounded by members of the security
services
a spokesman said they'd been provided
for his own
safety you know the dusty road that
leads to
bobby wines house is starting to
resemble a military installation now
there are a lot of troops there are
special forces
there are riot police and we've seen
several prison vans go in
signs are ominous we found the
opposition leaders spokesman
in a car wondering if there was anything
he could do i've just spoken to
uh honourable chagulani bobby wine
he's effectively under house arrest
and as you can see they're not allowing
anybody to access him
where he is anybody that tries to get
there gets clobbered and gets beaten
so the soldiers have jumped into the
fence
so he's defenseless he's there with just
the wife
mr wine has called the election the most
fraudulent poll in ugandan history
and says he'll post video evidence
online
however the government has switched off
the internet
and moved the military onto the streets
john sparks sky news
kampala